when and how to reopen parts of the
economy have become highly charged
political issues now that some states
have moved forward are we seeing any
health effects Washington Post national
correspondent Phillip Baum wrote about
it in the paper this week he joins us
with that and a whole lot more Phillip
good morning to you the president wants
the not only fast-track of vaccine but
also reopen the economy but reeling from
this pandemic as we know does not have a
one-size-fits-all solution talk about
why that is so complicated well it's
complicated for a number of reasons I
mean the first and foremost obviously is
the fact that each individual place
state municipality county has to figure
out when and if it's actually ready to
start letting businesses get back to
work at the same time even when they say
hey let's go economies let's have people
started coming back to restaurants and
bars and so on and so forth it's up to
individuals themselves to determine
whether or not they're actually ready to
do so so one of the things we've seen in
Georgia for example is that people
haven't really been willing to re-engage
in the economy because they're still
worried about the risks that the bars
poses Phillip right now all eyes are on
those states that have begun the process
of reopening right and lifting some of
those restrictions or a lot of the
restrictions is it too early to tell if
those states will pay a price or not for
reopening too soon it's it's too early
to tell broadly I think it's safe to say
we you know it has been more than two
weeks which is the window at which we
look because that's generally seen as
the broadest extent of the incubation
period so far when we look at the
numbers as I did this week there hasn't
been a huge uptick in the number of
cases or in the number of new positive
confirmations of the virus of infections
in those states at every open which
obviously is good news it is still early
but it is also the case that cases there
are growing faster than in cases where
the economy has remained most of the
shuttered Philip and Nicole outlined the
three trillion dollar coronavirus relief
package that the house narrowly passed
an obviously Republican opposition the
president has vowed to veto that
included in that was help for state and
local governments so what does this mean
right now for them well Republican
leadership in the Senate and president
Trump Express
very vocal opposition to providing
assistance to state and local
governments this is a huge problem it's
a huge problem in part because these are
state local governments which are
actually providing funding for some of
these first responders which are
critical to the fight the virus and so I
think there is this tension that exists
between an opposition to providing more
assistance to those governments and the
urgency with which those governments
actually need the funding right now I'm
not sure how that gets resolved clearly
the Republican leadership and the
president said that this bill was a
no-go but it may just be an opening
gambit to try and resolve this new graph
later 36 million job lost claims in the
past couple months obviously the economy
is hurting where are we in this balance
of trying to get the economy back and
people being concerned with doing the
right thing for health yeah it's really
uncertain we're in this very awkward
period where there are people generally
if you look at polling people really
understand that need to wear masks they
understand the need to try and stay home
as much as possible they understand why
we were doing this right now
and because of that because people have
internalized the risks that were seeing
these stories about what happens when
you have this viral infection people are
not willing to engage broadly I mean we
do see certainly there are some people
who are engaging in the economy there
are some people who are protest in the
shelter film orders but those people are
a minority in the country and until
people feel comfortable in going out and
behaving as they would have four months
ago people aren't going to behave as
they would have four months ago and
that's why things like the vaccine are
so urgent Philip we were already
recession bound when we had to literally
halt the economy here so if you can spin
it forward and look in the crystal ball
a little bit what does this mean for our
economy as we go forward yeah I mean
it's obviously become a huge hit you
know we could see unemployment hitting
over 20 percent the long-term
ramifications of the question president
Trump has said that we can probably see
a quick rebound a lot of economists
disagree and that's really the question
mark over the long term all right Philip
bump thank you we appreciate the insight